[Music]
augustine is with us he's in uh
coeur d'alene idaho hi augustine how are
you
good how are you better than i deserve
what's up
so i'm 21 and i bought a house this
january before i turned 21 because i
really wanted to like that was my goal
in high school
and uh so i did it but now work has been
really up and down and so every once in
a while like i'll have a trouble making
the payments so i want to make extra
cash rather than just working
but the house has made about a hundred
thousand dollars in equity in the last
seven months so my question is
should i sell it and have more to put
down on a regular down payment like a
bigger down payment on a different house
or
like use it as an airbnb style
or something else like that
what do you do for a living
i work on elevators
what's your extra job
um i my second i was working at a um at
a marina for a second job when it was
slow
now works then works picking back up so
i'm i'm making
i
make 38 an hour right now
at the elevator job which is like it's a
good job but it's just kind of sketchy
so i was just curious
what do you mean by sketchy as far as
well
yeah it's volatile
it's considered construction work
it goes up and down with the amount of
work that we're able to pull in
so
when work is good like when we have a
lot of
big jobs or whatnot work is great i
can't complain and payments are super
easy and i have no struggles
but when it's slow like when
like we finish a big job and it's like
slow for a month or so and it's like
okay well now what now
i really it comes i think comes down to
a budgeting question but
it comes down to a career question
because you're never going to be able to
establish a life with a income that is
not that is not steady enough
that you can you know make enough money
during the year to eat
right sure because here's the thing
if it doesn't matter if you have some
down if you have some months that the
income disappears
uh as long as you have enough months
that it doesn't and the overall
average for the year is still an
excellent income i mean if you make 500
000 a year you don't but if you make 500
000 a year and you have two months with
no income it's not a big deal
right right so the point is you're not
making any money
it's not just the volatility it's the
overall income is not enough to support
you
they're not working you enough to where
at the end of the year when you add it
up you had a good job
that's what i'm saying
so i think you got a career problem i
think you got a house problem you may
need to sell your house to step into
your next career or you may need to look
for a different place to
apply your trade
um
because you you know 38 bucks an hour is
pretty sweet income
uh but not if you're not getting it
right
so
because i mean
if you're 31 you don't need to be making
the same phone call with this same
income problem agreed
agreed agreed so that you got to solve
the career problem and then that'll tell
you what to do at the house no you don't
do airbnb
you either get this career thing solved
and keep the house or you sell the house
put the money in the bank until you get
the career thing solved one of those two
things but the last thing you need some
other goob living in your house you know
you're trying to pay payments and maybe
they don't show up because of covid
and you know maybe idaho decides to lose
its dadgum mind like some of these other
places and now you're just shut down and
you don't need all this risk man you're
21 you got 100 000 bucks on the table
take your money and run
sit over there in an apartment and get
yourself solved or get yourself solved
and keep the house one of the twos what
i would do yeah we need some stability
here and a financial foundation i don't
know if you have any debt but if you do
sell the house i want you to make sure
you're following the baby steps you
clean up the debt you have an emergency
fund that way when you get into a house
again you're not going to be having this
problem where you're having anxiety
about being able to afford the payment
in case something goes bad in case you
know you can't find some work but i do
think you need to find a career that's
stable with a steady paycheck right now
at your age
yeah
it is a bit um i had trouble not
laughing
his income goes up and down in the
elevator business okay i'm just saying i
missed that that was way over my head
i'm just i just yeah that was straight
yeah that's no that's clever yeah well
it is what happened i mean
that's the business it goes up
that's a papa dave joke right there